if my future spawn turns out even
remotely as idiotic as the two children
in this movie I'm gonna consider my life
a complete failure the purge stars Ethan
Hawke and Lena Headey this movie is
about a world in which crime on one
night each year is completely legal
including murder you can do basically
anything you want one night a year
and the way they explain this is saying
that basically humans are a violent
species and this one night each year
allows us to cleanse ourselves of our
impurities it allows everyone to get
everything out of them and do whatever
they want so we focused in on Ethan
Hawke and his family and they are locked
down in their extremely expensive home
with their extremely expensive security
system and lo and behold there are some
people wearing creepy masks outside who
want to come in and kill them and it
becomes a rather rough night for
everyone involved the purge is a movie
that I was looking forward to
specifically for one reason I really
like Ethan Hawke I'm a big fan of his he
is a great actor he's also a very good
writer if you guys have never seen the
film's before sunrise and before sunset
they are two of my favorite romance
films if not my favorite romance films I
can't wait for before midnight it's
going to come to Cleveland pretty soon I
can't wait to see it but Ethan Hawke is
a really good actor I was really
impressed with him last year in sinister
and despite the fact that this film
tries to have some big ideas in regards
to politics and things like that and
actually have some messages and meetings
it really just a bulges into a very
wrote and cliched thriller that has good
performances by its two leads and except
for maybe like one surprise this entire
movie is essentially very very
predictable and even that surprised that
they had in there didn't like it didn't
work for me
Ethan Hawke and Lena Headey are
definitely the two bright spots of this
movie those are two very talented actors
and they both give a lot to their
characters and I believed every second
they were on screen every word that came
out of their mouth seemed real and those
two actors did a great job in the movie
however their children wow that kid okay
look I could not stand the Sun in this
movie first of all the entire film
wouldn't even be there if it wasn't for
this one kids a little idiotic decision
and he continues to make stupid idiotic
decisions throughout the entire movie
and no one ever looks at him it goes you
know what we're kind of all in this
situation because of you actually you
kind of made a big mistake
you really did actually make a huge
mistake and you're continuously making
even warm it's
I get it the kid was trying to be
compassionate he has like a moment of I
don't understand this and I agree as an
audience you watch this movie like wow
this is all really horrible I can't
believe a world actually exists where
this is all okay which is actually
another problem with this movie I had a
really hard time believing that
something like this would ever actually
come about but you have to kind of
accept that as a plot to be able to get
into the movie I couldn't really accept
it it just seems so stupid everyone was
so calmly and quietly talking about oh
yes this is a night where everyone goes
around kills everyone and rapes everyone
kills babies and stuff yeah it's fine it
cleanses us it's beautiful no it's it's
disgusting it's horrible it's like why
would anyone actually I just couldn't
buy into it but that kid that kid in
this movie is the kid that gets everyone
into the situations all the problems
that arise in this movie are because of
that kid and I couldn't stand him he was
such a stupid character he was just a
thing to progress the plot along he
wasn't a person he was just there to
make the movie possible and the daughter
is equally as dumb she makes some of the
stupidest decisions of any of the
characters throughout this movie and you
continuously are like what what like
there's this one scene where they're all
separated throughout the house and
separation is not a good thing tonight
because you know there's people everyone
want to kill you you should stay
together right no they they split up
like 10 times throughout the movie of
course they let's split up and look
around like who in the world would do
that
you don't split up you stay together
there's people trying to kill you you
don't split up what does that even mean
split up but there is this one scene
where they all come back together and
she's like oh it's nice to see you mom
you know I'm kind of mad I'm gonna walk
away and the moms like come into the
safe room come into the safe room and
she's like no and just walks off
somewhere in the house where did she go
why did she go away why doesn't she come
into the safe room they're murderers
everywhere
you should come into the safe room you
know and so my biggest problem with this
movie really is just the fact that it's
so cliched and stupid in regards to the
horror films that generally are around
there's some really good ideas here and
there's some good performances and Ethan
Hawke is really good in this movie it's
a movie that I can see the actors
sitting down and going wow there's some
really good ideas here this says some
stuff about society and about humans in
general and that's probably why some of
these actors signed on to this movie but
the film and the way it was made and
crafted turns out to be just your
general cliched horror home invasion
thriller with a slight little twist in
there that it's legal on this one
for that reason I think the purge really
fails because it's a film that's trying
to have big ideas but it's showing it in
the most cliched and idiotic way I'm
gonna give the purge a c-minus it has
two good performances and a couple good
scenes but everything is so predictable
and you can guess for every little thing
is going even the jump scares like all
music will fade out completely for like
a second and you know okay it's dead
silence so some heads about the popular
window or something and each time sure
enough it does what do you guys think of
it did you see the film let me know what
you think below and as always guys
thanks for watching and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]